marion sinaly bonsoir et bienvenue parmi
les différentes opérations que vous avez
piloté donc avec la rs je rappelle que
vous êtes directrice départementale de
la rs dans les yvelines
en début de semaine un dépistage géant
de lakovic 19 étaient organisées au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sur trois
jours à destination des entreprises
une opération assez inédites voire
unique en france
quel est ce bilan de ces trois jours
justement est ce que vous le mans faire
le bilan
trois jours intensifs en plus j'imagine
oui tout à fait on a organisé cette
cette manifestation ce dispositif
à l'initiative de l'agglomération de 50
ans qui nous avait sollicités durant la
crise mais on n'avait pas pu le faire et
donc là comme on déploie ses opérations
de dépistage dans l'ensemble de la
région et notamment dans les yvelines
puisque ça correspond à la 16eme
opération condense met pas dedans
rigueur si grande on a proposé à
l'agglomération de 50 ans de pouvoir le
faire à destination des salariés des
entreprises et donc on a eu
effectivement pas mal de passages on a
enregistré un passage à peu près de 1500
entre 1500 et 1600 personnes qui sont
venues se faire dépister sur les trois
jours et donc c'était vraiment qu'un
destination des entreprises quand vous
me disiez est ce qu'il y a eu uniquement
les salariés des patrons des pme et tpe
des grandes entreprises qui sont venues
se faire dépister
c'était effectivement au départ à
destination des salariés des entreprises
mais également on avait une file pour
les patients prioritaires puisqu'on sait
que là une grande difficulté en ce
moment d'accès au test donc on avait une
fiche spécifique pour les les patients
prioritaires symptomatique avec des
ordonnances ou bien des cas contacts de
cas positifs et qui aurait eu le petit
sms de l'assurance maladie qui leur
demande de venir se faire dépister et
donc on a accueilli ces gens là aussi on
a fait passer les messages à la fois via
l'agglo et les mairies des douze
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
pour que ces patients puissent être pris
en priorité
donc c'était pour les salariés des
entreprises des collectivités locales de
la ville de saint quentin et pour la
population générale d'accor donc
vraiment assez complet sur le public que
vous avez accueilli
est ce qu'il ya des inquiétudes à avoir
au vu du nombre d'augmentations de cap
politique de le département mais
également en france alors au niveau de
la région ile de france
on le sait maintenant ça fait plus de 15
jours qu'on a dépassé les seuils
d'alerté qu'on est on a été classé en
niveau rouge par santé publique france
pour ce qui concerne les yvelines
ça fait dix jours qu'on a dépassé les
seuils d'alert à la fois sur le niveau
d'incidence puisque aujourd'hui on est à
peu près à 58 pour cent mille habitants
en termes d'incidence est à la fois sur
le taux de positivité on est à 5,9
aujourd'hui donc oui il ya une
circulation très active du virus en ile
de france dans les yvelines aussi même
si c'est un département où le virus
circule moins dans d'autres départements
franciliens notamment paris et la petite
couronne
mais ceci étant ça circule et c'est vrai
que sur ces opérations de dépistage
qu'on mène on constate aussi une
positivité plus importante
j'imagine en corrélation forcément avec
l'augmentation du nombre de tests
ce nombre d'augmentations de cas
positifs est ce que c'est parce qu'on
teste plus haut si aujourd'hui il ya une
raison oui c'est parce qu'on teste plus
mais ceci étant on constate que les taux
de positivité augmente nettement plus
vite que le taux de dépistage
supplémentaire donc c'est pas
complètement mathématiquement on peut
pas s'y retrouver
certains des pistes plus donc on trouve
plus de positivité mais il ya aussi
quand même beaucoup plus de cas positifs
ça veut dire que le virus circule
beaucoup plus très bien beaucoup
beaucoup de chiffres alors bon faut-il
s'inquiéter est ce que il faut
s'inquiéter justement de ces
augmentations alors ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il ne faut pas justement réduire les
et aux barrières est-ce que vous avez
des conseils justement fait maintenir
les gestes barrière le port du masque
évidemment veillez toujours à garder une
distanciation et puis se laver les mains
respecter aussi la distanciation même
entre amis en famille c'est important
parce que on voit peu voilà ce virus
circule et que les cas aujourd'hui
les taux d'incidence qui sont plus
important aujourd'hui c'est surtout
entre les
dans la tranche d'âge des 20 39 ans
parce que ce sont des évidemment la
tranche de la population qui voit le
plus de monde qui côtoie le plus de
monde qui a envie de sortir de voir de
la famille etc
et c'est là que le virus circule le plus
donc il faut vraiment être vigilant
d'accord et pour en revenir à ce
dépistage sur les trois jours au
vélodrome national de saint-quentin est
ce que vous avez eu des retours sur les
retards justement de résultats de
communication des résultats en verre
envers les salariés et les gens qui se
sont fait dépister
alors aujourd'hui n'y a pas de retard
sur cette opération en tant que tel on
s'était engagés à des résultats en 24 à
48 heures les engagements sont tenus les
salariés ont leurs résultats donc
là-dessus il n'y a pas de difficultés
après c'est vrai qu'on a accueilli des
gens on a proposé à des gens qui ne
trouvaient pas de rendez vous en ville
qui n'avait rien à voir avec l'opération
de pouvoir venir se faire dépister pour
qu'ils puissent être pris en charge
rapidement d'accord et quels sont les
prochains dépistage justement pour ceux
qui n'auraient pas eu la chance de se
faire dépister ou la chance en tout cas
l'occasion de se faire dépister
quels sont les prochains dépistage
prévus dans le département quatre dates
la semaine prochaine mardi 15 si je me
trompe pas on sera à chevreuse ma
mercredi 16 on sera à
villennes-sur-seine jeudi 17 à epône et
vendredi 18 à saint germain et donc
c'est un dépistage ces dépistages sont
ouverts au public à tout le monde
exactement au public à tout le monde on
est sur la place de la mairie on enfin
il ya des adresses spécifiques et où
tout peut être dit ou sera disponible
par don sur le site de l' agence donc il
y aura toutes les informations et puis
les mairie communique évidemment donc
c'est destiné à tout le monde avec deux
fils toujours une file prioritaire et
une file pour les personnes qui veulent
venir se faire dépister mais qui n'ont
pas forcément de symptômes
eh bien merci mon cou marion signalé
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui dans
ce premier set 8 l'hebdo de la saison